Der langersehnte Augenblick ist da:
Nuran und Sarah,
vom Vater nach Ägypten entführt,
sind soeben mit ihrer Mutter
in Interlaken angekommen.
Komm, wir gehen gleich rein.
Es ist spätnachts um 1.30 Uhr.
Mutter und Töchter haben
eine beschwerliche Reise hinter sich.
Fünf aufreibende Jahre hat Karin
Trachsel um ihre Töchter gekämpft,
jetzt sind sie wieder zu Hause.
Die Erleichterung ist gross.
Hallo, Karin! Endlich!
Ja.
Ich bin auch froh.
Kaum angekommen versucht die Familie
an die Vergangenheit anzuknüpfen.
Als der Vater die Mädchen
nach Ägypten verschleppte,
waren Nuran und Sarah
zweieinhalb und vier Jahre alt.
Die Erinnerung an ihr Zuhause
ist verblasst.
* Liebliche Melodie
aus der Spieldose *
Auf diesen Moment haben
die Grossmutter und die beiden Onkel
fünf Jahre gewartet.
Karin Trachsel konnte ihre Töchter
bereits vor zwei Monaten
in Ägypten in die Arme schliessen,
musste aber bis heute
um die Ausreiseerlaubnis bangen.
Wir sind jetzt
schon länger zusammen.
Wir haben zusammen
auf die Ausreise gewartet.
Das Wiedersehen ist schön,
aber es war heute
sehr, sehr anstrengend.
Wir wussten bis am Mittag nicht,
ob es klappt oder nicht.
Es ist jetzt schön, hier zu sein.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Zwei Tage sind seit der Ankunft
der Mädchen vergangen.
Karin Trachsel
möchte mit ihren beiden Töchtern
die ihnen fremd gewordene Heimat
erkunden.
Sarah sperrt sich.
* Sie sprechen arabisch. *
(Ruft) Ja, ich komme gleich.
Die Mädchen wurden
aus ihrem gewohnten Umfeld gerissen.
Dass die Mutter Arabisch spricht,
hilft.
Sowohl Sarah als auch Nuran sind
verunsichert - jede auf ihre Weise.
Die Ältere verschliesst sich mehr.
Und die Kleine reagiert aggressiv.
Ich denke,
das braucht einfach auch Zeit.
Vielleicht können sie sich irgend-
wann auch ein wenig ausdrücken.
Dann können wir darüber sprechen.
Aber ich glaube, das ist noch
nicht der Moment, um einfach ...
Später werden sie es verstehen.
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Jetzt hat sie
meine Regenjacke angezogen.
Die gefällt ihr
wohl besser als ihre.
Im Moment
dürfen sie noch alles machen?
Im Moment dürfen sie sicher
noch mehr als später.
Man muss auch etwas Verständnis
haben für die Situation,
in der sie jetzt sind.
Auf den neu gekauften Trottinetten
geht es auf Entdeckungsreise.
Vor dem Haus
begegnen sie dem Grossvater.
Er wohnt in der Nachbarsgemeinde.
Wir gehen kurz zum Bahnhof.
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Sie sind ja schon sehr forsch
unterwegs? Nicht schüchtern.
Es geht eigentlich gut.
Wir waren auch schon im Dorf.
Wir entdecken die Sachen neu.
Das kommt mit der Zeit schon,
denke ich.
Und v.a. ist es sicher gut,
dass sie einander haben.
Sie helfen einander sehr.
Sie sind zu zweit und nicht alleine.
Das ist sicher hilfreich.
Gibt es etwas, wovor sie
draussen im Neuen Angst haben?
Ich denke, wovor sie am meisten
Angst hatten, ist die Sprache.
Aber das kommt mit der Zeit.
Weil sie gar kein Schweizerdeutsch
mehr können? - Genau.
Zählen kannst du doch:
eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Sie kann gerade nicht.
Sie will es gerade nicht sagen.
Auch die Mutter muss sich erst wieder
an ihre eigenen Kinder herantasten.
Sie sind ziemlich ...
Die Jüngere
ist ziemlich temperamentvoll.
Das ist manchmal schwierig,
weil ich noch nicht so gut weiss,
wie sie reagiert.
Sie waren ja lange fort.
Damals war sie noch ein Kleinkind
und jetzt ist sie ...
Jetzt steht ein Mädchen vor Ihnen.
- Ja.
Wie ist das für Sie als Mutter?
Sie schimpft jetzt
ständig über mich.
Sie beschimpft mich
eigentlich jetzt auf Arabisch.
Jetzt im Moment?
- Genau. Jetzt sagt sie es auf.
Was denn genau?
"Du bist eine Blöde."
Und solche Sachen.
Und das muss man schon ...
Das geht hier einfach nicht
oder in unserem Kulturkreis.
Und warum sagt sie das jetzt gerade?
Weil es nicht nach ihrem Kopf lief.
Das sind die Situationen,
in denen sie nachher
nach einer
anderen Situation schreien.
Dann sagen sie,
dass sie gerne wieder zurück wollen.
Dann wollen sie zu Papi gehen.
- Ja, genau.
Aber das ist ja
bei allen Trennungskinder so.
Sobald es schwierig wird, schreien
sie nach dem anderen Elternteil.
Haben sie auch Heimweh?
Sagen sie das?
Ja, sie sagen manchmal schon, dass
sie v.a. die Leute dort vermissen.
Den Vater? - Die Cousins,
die Geschwister, den Vater auch.
Natürlich fragen sie manchmal,
das ist klar.
Und wie wollen Sie
die Beziehung zum Vater handhaben?
Grundsätzlich bin ich der Meinung,
dass das Kind das Recht
auf Mutter und Vater hat.
Und äh ...
Wir haben auch schon versucht,
mit ihm zu telefonieren.
Beim ersten Mal ging es gut.
Beim zweiten Mal begann er
mit Vorwürfen gegen die Kinder.
"Warum seid ihr mitgegangen?"
"Bald seid ihr gross genug,
dann könnt ihr selber sagen,
wo ihr leben wollt."
"Ruf mich von der Schule aus an,
wenn dich die Mutter
nicht telefonieren lässt."
Dann muss man einfach sagen,
dass es im Moment wohl nicht geht.
Jetzt müssen wir
etwas Gras darüber wachsen lassen.
Dann kann man es
noch einmal versuchen.
* Muezzinruf aus einem Lautsprecher *
Ägypten. Die Heimat ihres Ex-Mannes.
Hierhin hat er
die gemeinsamen Töchter entführt.
Diese Aufnahmen von Karin Trachsel
entstanden
vor rund dreieinhalb Jahren.
Um ihren Mädchen nahe zu sein,
zog die Lehrerin
von Interlaken nach Kairo.
Sie durchlebt gerade einen Albtraum.
Dabei
hatte alles so romantisch begonnen.
Während meines Studiums
habe ich aushilfsweise
bei McDonald's gearbeitet.
Dort lernte ich ihn kennen,
in der Schweiz.
Er war dazumal noch
mit einer Schweizerin verheiratet.
Er war in der Trennung.
Dort habe ich ihn kennengelernt.
Er und vielleicht auch
die fremde Kultur
haben mich am Anfang fasziniert.
Ich hatte das Gefühl:
"Ja, das wäre jetzt ...
... der Mann, mit dem ich das Leben
verbringen möchte."
Im Laufe der Zeit begann er sich
wirklich zu verändern.
Er wurde auch immer religiöser -
fast fanatisch.
Dann kam häusliche Gewalt ins Spiel.
Da musste ich sagen: "Bis hierher,
und weiter geht es nicht."
Karin Trachsels Odyssee begann,
als das Regionalgericht Thun
ihrem Ex-Mann das Recht auf Ferien
mit den Kindern
in seinem Heimatland zuspricht.
Er und die Kinder
kehren nie mehr zurück.
In Ägypten
nimmt sich die Mutter einen Anwalt.
Doch nach ägyptischem Gesetz hat
der Vater keine Straftat begangen.
Auch das Amt
für auswärtige Angelegenheiten, EDA,
kann nichts bewirken.
Nach langem Kampf
ein Hoffnungsschimmer:
Karin Trachsel gewinnt
wenigstens eine Tochter zurück.
Als ihr Mann ein Treffen mit dem
älteren der beiden Mädchen erlaubt,
taucht sie mit diesem unter.
Trotz Ausnahmezustand: Die Mutter
versucht ihrer älteren Tochter
ein Stück heile Welt zu bieten.
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Machst du auch einen Mund?
- Ja.
Doch die jüngere Tochter Sarah fehlt.
Wie es der Kleineren im Moment geht,
weiss ich nicht.
Ich habe null Kontakt.
Ich durfte nicht einmal an ihrem
Geburtstag mit ihr telefonieren.
Das ist der zweite Geburtstag,
an dem ich nicht dabei war.
Das sind schwierige Tage.
Ohne väterliche Erlaubnis
oder richterliche Verfügung
darf die Mutter mit Nuran
nicht ausreisen.
Was für sie, ohne jüngere Tochter
Sarah, sowieso undenkbar ist.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
besteht noch Hoffnung.
Karin Trachsel erkämpft sogar
in Ägypten das alleinige Sorgerecht.
Aber: Die Behörden
setzen den Entscheid nicht um.
Es mangelt
an Willen und Dringlichkeit.
Immer wieder erfährt Karin Trachsel
niederschmetternde Rückschläge.
(Englisch)
* Traurige Klavierklänge *
In der Schweiz unterstützt die
Grossmutter Karin Trachsels Kampf.
Via Skype versucht sie,
Karin aufzubauen.
Im Frühling 2016 hat die Verzweiflung
ihren Höhepunkt erreicht:
* Freiton *
Tochter Nuran
wurde Karin erneut genommen.
Eine von ihrem Ex-Mann angeheuerte
Männerbande schlug sie nieder
und entriss ihr das Kind.
Ein Schritt bevor sie
in den Bus eingestiegen wäre,
kommt plötzlich eine Gruppe Männer
mich und auf Nuran zu.
Mich haben sie niedergeschlagen.
Ich lag dort am Boden.
Als ich wieder auf war, sah ich,
wie jemand Nuran trägt.
Er hat sie in ein Auto
ohne Nummernschild gesetzt.
Ich habe
den Vater von Nuran gesehen.
Er kam zurück, schlug auf mich ein
und sagte:
"Hast du gesehen, was passiert?"
"Ich finde dich überall."
Karin, geht es noch?
Ich kann mir ein Leben
ohne die Kinder nicht vorstellen.
Wenn ich aufgeben würde,
würde das heissen, dass ich meine
zwei Kinder einfach abschreibe.
Ich kann nicht.
Wenige Wochen später
kommt es erneut zu einer Wende.
Karin Trachsel
kehrt in die Schweiz zurück,
wo ihre Tante
am Flughafen auf sie wartet.
Bin ich froh, dich zu sehen.
Auf direktem Weg geht es ins Spital.
Karin Trachsels Mutter
wurde am Herzen operiert.
Hallo!
Ich kenne dich ja gar nicht mehr.
Mein Mädchen.
So, Mutter.
* Die Mutter weint. *
Ist alles gut gegangen?
- Ja.
Wir waren sogar ziemlich pünktlich.
Für ägyptische Verhältnisse.
Komm, ich nehme dir die ab.
Warst du aufgeregt?
Auf der einen Seite habe ich
sehr Freude, dass sie hier ist.
Aber sie ist ohne Kinder hier.
Noch.
Ich hole hier jetzt erst mal Anlauf.
Das war ein Versprechen,
das ich mir selber gegeben habe:
Ich will nicht ohne sie noch einmal
kommen müssen. Aber jetzt ...
Ihr Kampf kostet nicht nur Kraft,
sondern auch Geld.
Rund eine halbe Million Franken haben
die Trachsels bereits ausgegeben.
Die Reserven sind aufgebraucht.
Karin Trachsel bleibt nichts anderes
übrig, als in der Schweiz zu bleiben,
um Geld zu verdienen.
Sie wirkt erschöpft, mutlos.
Zwar wurde ihr Ex-Mann
wegen des Überfalls auf sie
erstinstanzlich zu einem Jahr
Gefängnis verurteilt.
Auf Kaution frei,
tauchte er mit den Mädchen unter.
Kein Lebenszeichen mehr. Nichts.
Ich denke immer, dass es schade ist,
dass die Kinder
darunter leiden müssen,
unter dem Konflikt.
Dass zwei Kinder,
die alle Perspektiven hatten,
jetzt irgendwo in einer Wohnung
eingesperrt sind.
Sie können nicht hinaus,
nicht in die Schule.
Ja.
Wieder ist ein Jahr vergangen,
und von den Kindern
fehlt noch immer jede Spur.
Lichtlaternen für Nuran und Sarah.
Die Mutter kämpft
mit Solidaritätsaktionen wie dieser
gegen das Vergessen.
Muss man die Hoffnung
vielleicht einmal begraben?
Ich glaube,
das kann man einfach nicht.
Das wird immer da sein.
Wenn ein Kind stirbt, kann man
vielleicht irgendwie abschliessen.
Aber diese Kinder sind ja irgendwo.
Früher oder später werden sie sich
auch fragen, wo sie herkommen.
Vielleicht finden wir uns dann
auf diesem Weg wieder,
wenn es vorher nicht klappen sollte.
Über zwei Jahre hat die Mutter nichts
mehr von ihren Töchtern gehört,
bis sich die ägyptischen Behörden
im Dezember auf einmal
des Falles annehmen.
Dann geht es schnell.
Weshalb dieser Sinneswandel?
Das EDA schweigt.
Und auch die Trachsels
halten sich bedeckt.
Warum jetzt?
Wir wissen eben nicht ganz genau,
was vorher im Weg war.
Es kann auch sein, dass sich
dort einfach irgendjemand sperrte.
Dann gab es personell
vielleicht einen Wechsel.
Und dann ging es, also nicht
beim EDA, sondern in Ägypten.
Jetzt haben sie
vielleicht eine neue Strategie.
Es sind ja die Ägypter
auf euch zugekommen. - Genau.
Sie haben gesagt ...
Sie möchten nun doch helfen.
Sie sehen, dass man das
umsetzen muss und äh ... ja ...
Ihre Mädchen sind wieder da.
Das ist für die Familie Trachsel
die Hauptsache.
Auch wenn es
Startschwierigkeiten gibt.
Unterschiede.
Wie z.B. Essgewohnheiten.
Wä!
Dass die Grosseltern
kein Arabisch sprechen,
erschwert die Annäherung zusätzlich.
* Sie spricht arabisch. *
Ich kann auf etwas zeigen oder ...
äh ... Gesten machen.
Das ist ...
Und der Grossvater ist sicher der,
der mehr Zugang hat.
Sarah ist v.a. sehr auf ihn fixiert.
Er macht einfach alles gut.
Im Moment.
Sie hat mir vorher gesagt, dass sie
mit dem Grossvater spielen gehen,
ich könne die Küche machen.
Also das ist ...
Das ist eben ein Rollenbild,
dass sie mitbekommen haben.
Das haben sie gesehen.
Bevor die Mädchen
nach Ägypten verschleppt wurden,
haben die Grosseltern
oft auf ihre Enkelinnen aufgepasst.
Gibst du mir die Gondel, Nuran?
Darf ich sie haben? Das hier.
Ja.
Nun müssen sich
alle wieder neu kennenlernen.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, dass Sie
das Richtige gemacht haben:
Die Kinder dort
aus ihrem Leben herauszureissen
und hier
noch einmal neu starten zu lassen?
Das habe ich mir
schon auch überlegt,
ob ich das den Kindern
noch einmal antun soll.
Aber schlussendlich
muss man einfach sagen,
dass sie hier
die bessere Umgebung haben als dort.
Die Schulbildung ist besser,
dem Land geht es besser.
Ich glaube, dann muss man das
einfach in Kauf nehmen.
Auch wenn das
im ersten Moment schlimm ist.
Aber sie sind noch jung genug,
um sich anzupassen.
Ich glaube, in diesem Fall
gibt es kein richtig und falsch.
Es sind immer zwei Parteien da,
die beide ...
... Parteien irgendwann
leiden müssen. Das ist so.
Das tut mir auch leid.
Wir wollten
viel mehr und viel intensiver
nach einer Möglichkeit suchen,
dass die Kinder
in beiden Ländern leben können.
Aber der Vater
hat das nicht zugelassen.
* Sanfte Harfenklänge *
Hallo!
Salut, salut.
Der Onkel kommt
mit den kleinen Cousins zu Besuch.
Sie wollen gleich rauf.
Zuerst ziehen wir die Schuhe aus.
Jetzt kann man es herausnehmen.
Willst du noch mehr?
Was kannst du noch machen?
Hei.
* Alle lachen. *
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Nein!
Hast du ihn gesehen?
- Schlitzohr.
Sie waren dort eben in einer grossen
Familie und sassen oft zusammen.
Das müssen wir ihnen auch bieten.
Einfach auch mit unserer Familie
und mit Kollegen, die Kinder haben.
Ich denke, wenn immer etwas läuft,
gewöhnen sie sich daran.
Jetzt braucht es noch ein wenig
Zeit, um richtig anzukommen.
Ihre Töchter sind wieder da.
Diesen Kampf
hat Karin Trachsel gewonnen.
Der Kampf um die Gunst der Kinder
aber wird noch eine Weile dauern.